hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
edition of ask Evan today i'm answering
the question from one of our facebook
readers Jonathan throw it insane Evan I
don't know if this is the right platform
but my problem is I have too many
interest I'm really confused about
probably in a passion for starting a new
business venture he's got a lot of stuff
here so I'm a mechanical engineer by
training but I have interest varying
from electronics motoring home design
landscaping graphic design and so on
what do i do to really find my true
calling currently I own an advertising
business so Jonathan is all over the map
and that's very common partner so thank
you for the question your best bet as an
entrepreneur and it's and it's great
that you have lots of different
interests and we all do right there
aren't many people who only have one
interest in your life and so it's great
that you have lots of different
interests and you'll find that your your
best chance of success as an
entrepreneur is to combine these
different interests into one thing that
makes you unique so if you look at any
of those things that you do if you're
into electronics or home design or more
during or any of those things if you
just did one of them then you'll be okay
at it you know you may be better than
average at it because you're going to
put in the time and effort in the
thought into making it work but where
you really have a lot of success is
trying to combine some of those two
things or three things together because
that's going to be uniquely you and
you're going to attract the right kind
of clientele love seeing what you do
you're gonna be able to put a lot more
passionate energy into it because you're
combining various skills and interests
into it and you'll eventually have a lot
more success so you need to find ways as
an entrepreneur to stand out you need to
find a way to differentiate yourself and
the way to do it is to combine lots of
different things that you're super
passionate about and have skills at that
nobody else can do that's what makes you
unique that's what's going to make you
the expert in your field a quick example
so a story I met with a local
entrepreneur here friend of mine is it
was rich he's a fashion photographer and
he works with celebrities he's done lady
gaga all sorts of different pictures for
celebrities and there's a lot of
competition in that field to right how
many photographers are there out there
and he was telling me about he has his
passion for
an alternative lifestyle so he does
unschooling with his kids and he is
looking for natural ways to use
deodorant who uses lemon instead of do
durand all these funky things and he's
an awesome guy but a little off the wall
and so his best clients would be the
ones who a little bit off the wall as
well and he wanted to start this blog
he's coming up how do I come up with
content for my web site how to create
good content for my site and he was
trying to figure out a way to have this
fashion photography celebrity you know
photography business but then also have
this other blog or not sure what to do
with it talking about the things that
are bent just to his own you know
personality his lifestyle and I
suggested the best thing for him to do
there is combine them because that's
where the real strength the power is
going to be making what what he is
unique and you may turn some people off
you know talking about unschooling you
know if you're talking to parents who
really believe in the school system
unschooling is not going to really you
know be a good fit for them or if you're
talking about how you use lemon as a
deodorant that might throw people off
right there may be a little too off the
wall for them and they may not want to
work with you but those are not going to
be ideal types of clients you know so
which works with celebrities great
there's a lot of different celebrities
out there the ones who are going to
attract the best type of client for him
I'll give me the ones for little off the
wall just like him and if he's posting
content on the site that's talking about
these things even it's not related to
what he does is a business but is
related to his passion and that's coming
through then the people who see that
when they're making the decision who to
go with has a photographer and they see
rich with all these crazy interests that
also kind of line up with what they're
all about then those are going to be the
people who will pick rich over everybody
else so he's going to attract people who
are more interested in his way of doing
business and in his lifestyle and
they'll be better clients you know the
guys even if he doesn't market himself
as somebody who likes unschooling and
using lemon as a deodorant the guys who
are really against that whoo-hoo don't
think differently who are inside the box
they're not going to get along with rich
that well you know it might be a good
one time deal that he does with them but
it's not going to be an ongoing awesome
client relationship that he's going to
have
he'd rather have those strange kind of
off-the-wall types of clients because
he's a little strange an off the wall
and so by combining those interests it's
not it's not a bad thing for your
business it's a good thing and so it's
finding the right clientele to niche
yourself out in to be an expert in and
be able to grow your business from there
so hopefully that helps it may be making
yourself a little vulnerable and showing
you know sides of you that you you you
know may not have wanted the show before
but it's gonna it's going to make you
more real more genuine it's going to
attract them much better clientele and
you're going to have much more success
so I look at that big list of things
that you're interested in and try to
find a way to combine the top two or
three of them into one awesome business
that's going to add a lot of value to
people's lives you're going to make a
lot of money by adding a lot of people a
lot of value to people's lives so it's
whatever you end up doing it has to help
people that's the bottom line you know
if you're not helping people then it
might just be a hobby or something
you're doing for yourself which is
awesome but if you want to come into a
business and have success then it has to
be some way to combine your interest
into one mega company a product service
that's really going to have an impact on
this world and help a lot of people so
hopefully that helped maybe not the
answer you were looking for but that
that would be my best suggestion and I'm
really excited for you I think there's
an opportunity there that by combining
those passions you could really turn it
into something special now you could be
proud of so for those of you watching
and thank you for joining me for another
edition if you guys liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below it
makes you want to do more videos for you
and I'd love to hear what you have to
say if you want to leave a comment under
the video when i wake up but i see the
comments coming it always makes my day
so thank you and we'll see you on the
next episode
you